welcome this video silver with black
mm-hmm yeah played this guy a couple of
times before with a good score for one
let's play some non-standard stuff for
once modern defense ray goes from a very
normal looking and development moves
sort of solid play don't want to lose
that pawn yeah that's probably comes
with the territory with the modern
defense that you have some development
issues Knight f6 worried about f5
hitting
if I buy I hope that I can hope Bishop
f3 Bishop f3 takes f6 f6
can also take your five first maybe the
clearer clearer way to do it so Bishop
to Bishop FC f3 ef ef was my idea
don't don't see yet why it shouldn't
work
I might maybe I run into some kind of
pin I mean GF f kg 5 P should be five
but it looks that looks very it doesn't
look like it should work
yeah not not totally Jack sure yeah this
is he can do queen is seven is now of
course possible just for fur trading
Queens maybe this is the the simple way
to do it
moving the King does look strange anyway
so TCM so I want a pawn how good is it
however it's not bad it's a kind of a
stretch bond structure with the e pawn
having captured twice and this is a
really rich style porn GG pawn when you
still have an H and F pawn it's very
rare if I get to take something on h4
later this is probably almost an unique
unique kind of pawn structure and okay
so I can take here he can give the check
on d6 but it's just check right
I just want to take there first and then
decide
probably just castling you know probably
just castling don't see any a
spectacular move leading to something
leading to anything
yeah I'm caught up with a good position
so that was nice but how do I continue
from here 95 maybe I'm centralizing and
she cannot take any of those any of
those points for like effort is about
this is even though even moves f5 but
Knight takes Queen takes e5 is probably
possible
d 3 maybe I'm not sure it looks some
nice in any case come on let's let's
play one movie and see about this later
yeah so here I've got Queen a 393 those
kind of ideas
Jack yeah I don't know probably this
wasn't the best possible way to do it
but it should be should still be quite
good for like got the a porn as a
valuable asset and a very very
satisfying pawn structure satisfactory
porn structure yeah possibly this
activation this is on there come on Brad
I take with the pawn rook c1 is a bit
annoying I don't have many squares I can
go to a for them you know therefore is
okay it hampers my a pawn but I've
gotten an additional D pawn to push so
it's not that big of a problem
yeah but Queenie - I was thinking should
should decide really
if i takea he's taking the aid was chick
time warning what a shame
I queen d4 hmm
now I can still cover it
Queen f3 is quite a big threat and he
only has one check I think Jack maybe
Here I am still cannot check anywhere
and the rook hangs I mean it's not like
he can play any any any movie time check
check check
I absolutely needed a way to find to
lose this game it was not not really
different that was not easy at all
kameena form it's just great okay do I
want to analyze this really I don't
I hope you helped you had a good laugh
out of that thanks for watching